and i'm i'm
i'm just trying to be alive you know it
and this weekend i um and i ate a whole
sack of uh them toll house morsels
and they and they i don't know if you
ever seen them they got that yellow sack
they got that uh that amarillo
i think is how you say in in uh in
spanish they got that amore
bolsa that yellow sack
of them little chocolate you know little
nuggets
look like i mean they look like almost
like a little duty or something
like a like a real little bitty bear
maybe a bear that's
you know about four inches tall came and
did a little duty somewhere
and that's the uh the nestle nestle i
believe
toll house morsels and they are good
and look you have here's the thing the
sack of them
the the way they built the sack if you
open it a bunch kind of spill out
so i don't know it's kind of like uh
i don't want to say it's like that movie
uh you know i'm a start or anything but
it's kind of you know
you know they got too many in the bag
kind of thing you know um
and so you know next thing you know they
got a couple of those
little sweet chocolate morsels just you
know maybe you put a couple in your hand
or
but then it's you know some spill on the
counter next thing you know you've had
11 19 and i probably had no
i don't even really want to be honest
with myself about it i probably had
240 of them
two you know so that's
i mean i guess that's kind of where i'm
at right now you know
but uh let's get into it
[Music]
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering
[Music]
i'll patch up where it's been
these leaves i must be cornerstone
[Music]
baby
a little come on let's go we could do it
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself go
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
thank you uh hey what's up that is
shine by bishop gunn and they are a band
out of
natchez uh louisiana
or mississippi sorry and it's so close
you can't even tell which one you're in
i mean you could uh if you had really
long legs you could be in
in mississippi and louisiana at the same
time
you're gonna have to probably be at
least about i would guess
probably about eight feet tall because
you have to really
you're gonna you just need a little bit
of room you gotta make sure you're in
each one
uh because you gotta pod out at the
bottom sort of
thank you uh for joining me today
say um good to see you i hope you have
are doing
well i hope you are doing well and that
uh
that is shined by bishop gun i am
what's going on what's going on with me
i guess
it's summer time that's what i'm
realizing you know
and it's summer and this is the kind of
time of year i remember
when at summer time you go to the pool
you might see a little uh if you're
around that
age when you really when you got really
purple it kind of
starts kind of whispering in year
because perhaps if you're going through
puberty puberty is a real ghost
you know it's it's invisible to you for
years you were
you're a child and you know you don't
see nothing
when you're real young a titty could
roll across the street you don't care
you know a whole a battleship full of
wieners could just
you know capsize right out front of your
house if you're a young lady you don't
care you're like oh what is all it is
what are all of these you know these
weird you know
these weird little kind of arms you know
that
don't have bodies and hook to them
because you because that because that
that that puberty ghost hadn't started
really whispering to you
and then when you hit about 13 or 14
that ghost just
he kind of just
you playing video games and suddenly you
hear something in your ear like
what you think about some teddy
[Music]
and they'll try to pretend like they're
still a ghost but really they're just
it's just uh puberty coming at you
so but that's what time it is summertime
it's summertime and the kids i bet the
kids just
the you're inside i know the kids are
inside
it's starting to get a little
touchy feely i bet it's starting to get
a little bit intense you know it's
getting a little bit hot
hot but purity come and it really starts
it starts getting you going if you're
young remember
that's when summer would always uh
that's when uh puberty would always hit
somebody
in summer time that you feed that
long
i know you like playing hide and go seek
but what about uh
some titties
and everything started to change
you know you'd have a water slide at the
beginning of summer
and by the end of the summer you're
trying to you're trying to slide into
the neighbor's daughter
remember it was just different time it
just was it was same times actually but
it was
it was just i don't know it was just
something that happened that's
and your buddy come back from school he
have a beard you know
your friend you guys had pogs or
something together now he got a beard
and he got a child
he was in a war and you're like damn
you might you got some real you must
have that polish pyramid hit you or
something that you crying in bruh
cause you've already been in a couple
battles
but it's that summertime we're still
getting through it
what did i do this weekend i had look i
had some neat experience uh
i'll share about it in a second i you
know i was asking
or thinking last week who listens to the
show and i wanted to know and so uh
we got a couple of people that chimed in
and let us know here we go
hey theo um i'm calling from phoenix
arizona
oh phoenix arizona and
my mother used to live over there
outside of phoenix
and phoenix if you know arizona state
university
beautifulest they got some real
beautiful ladies running around over
there
i mean they got i'm surprised they not
they don't have real carnivores in that
area a lot of
because they got some ladies over there
you'll see some booty cheeks make you
want to damn get a fork and knife out
bruh
you know turn you into a little that
kind of snack of dactyl really
so but thank you for calling young lady
onward
um are a special ed teacher and i just
wanted to call and say
that you do a kick-ass job on on your
podcast
i normally listen to you when i'm
getting ready for work
oh you're a special ed teacher and
that's beautiful and i actually
you know a lot of people know that i've
you know beat down syndrome when i was
born and
and i've had a lot of you know i've had
interactions i'll tell you actually i
feel bad about this but
when i was in a third grade or first
grade
and who knows which one it was i mean
nobody really
you know nobody ever knows really enough
and they had a next to us was special
education
and um and i would sneak in there and
steal they had these
kind of orange slices and these lime
slices these kind of green little sugar
look like a little uh
like somebody like a little handful of
somebody
made a little sugar like a chewy sugar
chunk these little sugar hitters and i'd
sneak in there and eat them all
while the while the special-ed kids were
out doing recess or
just doing something i don't know what
they were doing just riding around town
or whatever
you know not at school or not in the
classroom
and um and honestly i've always felt a
little bit bad about that
so i want to apologize about that right
now
i would sneak in there and dude
sometimes i would lock myself
in the cab and the cupboard they had a
tall cupboard i'd get in there
and i'd start eating these candies
because our teacher miss lewis would
give you permission
to go to the restroom sometimes
if you were an appropriate child
now we had some inappropriate you know
we had some real inappropriates kind of
milling around we had kids who
you know alphabet deniers and stuff you
know kids that didn't want to read and
all kinds
but she would let you go get uh to the
to the restroom
until you be in the hall by yourself
so i'd sneak into the um special ed room
and get their candies and get in that
candy closet
and the second i opened that door they
had so many
candy they had
those uh tootsie roll the long ones you
know that kind of make you
fool that kind of make you really
they kind of make you start thinking
about what you're into as a young fella
you know you put two of them big fellas
in your mouth you might
you know you might uh you might end up
in a unique parade later on in
in your life and so i get in there and
i'd start just eating the lime slices
and eating i'd have probably maybe 30
pieces of candy
and then i'd come back to the class and
i'd have forgotten to go
urinate and so i'd have to sit there the
rest of the time and
suffer with the full bladder
and it's funny because the pain of
having to urinate
would almost be it would every time i
remembered i gotta pee so bad
i would feel ashamed because i had
stolen them children's candies
their sweet uh the sweet treats
and anyway i'm sorry i'm rambling yes
some thank you for calling in
onward since i'm a special ed teacher
and i work
right now in behavior specifically it's
very stressful
so i like to start off my day with one
of your
episodes because it just kind of sets me
in that mood to get ready
and be positive and know that everything
is going to be
okay so thank you dude for all that
you do thank me thank you
you know i think about that uh let's
brave you i
it's uh well it's not you have a special
gift to be able to work with children
that's really
you know that have autism or you know
unique gifts from god or they're
a lot of mentally challenged people it
seems like they're doing more insider
trading it seems
they're operating on the inside you know
we're out here operating on the outside
for the most part and some of us are
a hundred percent out here and nothing
inside and some of us are
or 50 50. but sometimes a lot of
you know mental children when i was
growing up it would seem they were um
they were uh they were
more like 80 inside 20 outside
so they had a lot more you know you got
a it's almost like a rubik's cube you
got to do a lot of twisting and turning
to kind of get the
get the walls to all match up and it
takes a lot of patience
so i can't even really imagine you know
um
how much patience you have to be i mean
you must
you must you must just have to be full
of patience because
uh i mean i just i imagine if we cracked
you open that
something would come out but only if we
waited a while
because that's patience you know like
i just can't imagine it you know and
and so thank you for for your service
right there and uh and thank you for the
compliment
and i hope you have a great day today
you know i hope you
you know uh and those kids that you're
working with in the future they get the
next go round they get the big trip next
time
you know we all we all take turns i
believe that
like i'm here this time doing what i do
being a loudmouth
and next time i'll be you know i'm kind
of a more sensitive loud mouth next time
i might be a warrior like a
deaf warrior so you'll see me with
no listening skills but maybe be a
lightweight champion of the world
or i might be like a you know a little
show animal or something
that you know doesn't do a lot and does
you know does cigarettes or something
so it's you know everybody gets the term
where you have
where we get to see what it's like to be
that next thing
that next type of person
so uh i guess i'm just envious
you know i had a day one time i was a
student and we went to
india uh earth
and we worked on a disabled children's
home over there
and a lot of these children they didn't
have wheelchairs or
chairs and
they were just crawling around on the
ground you know and uh
and our job for the day was to help move
they had different sediment and
different pieces of cement or something
i don't know what had happened
somebody left a probably look about two
dump trucks full of some
pieces of big cement at a at a disabled
children's home
and we moved it and we made it and moved
it around and opened up a little play
area for them but
uh but man it was
you know it was the one day in my life
where i really felt of service like a
hundred percent
i remember getting to the end of that
day and just feeling like wow man um
just felt so good um but thank you for
your service i'm glad we can get you
going i'm glad to be a part of whatever
we're doing here and
uh and getting you going so i hope you
have a wonderful day over there
uh let's get it who else is listening
let's carry out one more
my name is tim big tim out there
and you know tim is always that kind of
neighbor guy you know
he he's a little sometimes he'll be out
shooting hoops at night
but you're like damn what's going on tim
you you got a family you know
or tim's the kind of guy where you know
you won't have seen his wife for like a
month and you'd be like dang
tim oh where's diane
but let's hear more thank you for
listening tim and i listen to your
podcast
after i dropped my kids off oh yeah man
oh oh oh i see what you're saying actual
kids because that's a euphemism also
for uh going to the restroom onward
at school i'm a stay-at-home dad and i
sod
bruh damn
boy stay at home
dad wow
oh that'd be so much fun because i
remember staying at home when i was a
kid
[ __ ] was great making stuff making your
own food remember that
do one day for lunch bro i had 16 pieces
of cheese
[Music]
remember that cheese steaks i remember i
heard about
uh cheese steaks
and a cheese steak is when i guess i
don't know
but i thought it was that you just put a
bunch of cheese in
like a you know as much of a meat shape
as you could and just had that [ __ ] you
know
so i made a perfect t-bone out of cheese
out of about 16 pieces of american
you know what i'm saying gba boy god
bless them
and uh and had me a beautiful ass cheese
steak while i watched
it wasn't how uh one life to live or
something
my grandmother got me onto some of the
uh soap operas
and a soap opera is something basically
where it's like a lot of
i guess it's kind of where people
they fantasize i think about having sex
with somebody else but
instead of doing that they just watch a
soap opera and have a snack
um what else we got thank you for
calling tim let's hear more
and i just love how real you talk you
don't hold anything back
i'm in wisconsin and uh i'm sure you
know
like your vibe is felt the same
everywhere
but we definitely feel it out here all
right buddy
love you love you too tim man
uh thanks for calling and dude have fun
at the house today bruh
if what if the ladies out there working
dude get a slip and slide sell the
[ __ ] furniture dude online
dude you're living the dream do whatever
you want
oh man when you were at home that was
one thing nice during summertime when
you were home
wake up as long as there was milk
if there wasn't milk my day was going to
hell but if there was milk i was
i was feeling good because you could
have cereal get a little bit of this
cut on an episode of something do a
video game
you know and if you hadn't if you hadn't
hit perby yet you just do fun stuff all
day
see what the neighbors are up to make
sure the house keys under the mat when
you leave
dude how how crazy is it that we keep
the hou every house keys under the mat
if there's any bur if there's a burglar
who can't get into a house
[ __ ] him bruh then he ain't a good
burglar
let me every burglar i have to be honest
with you the house key
is under the mat or it's in the little
frog or it's on the little goose
they got a little trap door under the
frog and that's
the house key is right there
because sometimes you'll see a burglar
like they catch a burglar by like the
back window
he's back there with a screwdriver what
are you crazy there's no screws on a
window first of all bucko
dude the keys under the mat come in the
front door
just baffling to me sometimes what's
going on
uh this weekend for me what happened
this past weekend i'm just kind of
rambling
um
well oh longneck came out to the show
you know and we're distant cousins
people ask
and uh and so he came out
and it was a good experience man it was
nice to see him you know he's a young
guy
people don't realize it they think he's
just that necky neck neck
people all you know just think he's you
know he's naked even if he ain't he
could be fully clothed and still be
naked
you know he's that esophageal guy
you know it's like uh it's almost like
you can play that game where you put
your hands up a bat until somebody wins
you could do that right on my boy right
there
and his real name is david and he
doesn't smoke or drink
you know he doesn't do drugs
and he's a young guy people don't
realize that
he's a young dude there's no work for
his parents out there and uh
he lives in um outside of flint
and you know he's got a fa you know he's
got he
lives with his family but there's no you
know there's not a lot of opportunity
out there
so he said this is a really tough time
we had a nice time actually chatting he
said it's tough because
um there's a lot of gangs
there's a lot of like violence and stuff
a lot of people get jealous of him which
must be
wild it's like he kind of has this
unique look and then people get jealous
of him
um and he's only 19 so he's just
you know trying to be alive and he said
that p
some people have taken advantage of him
and
uh like in business and stuff like that
and but he had a nice group with him and
they came out
and we broke some bread backstage and
just had a nice meal
and he likes fries you know he likes uh
he likes french fries
he so mostly if you see him you know
just filling up his body it's with fries
so he's fried up but
but yeah it was a good time and we hung
out what else and the shows were great
so many great people came out
so many just man i just
man so many nice people the first show i
thought was really amazing the second
show was good it wasn't as good
uh to me but you know how i am i'm kind
of hard on myself
and uh but yeah we had a good time we
brought on we brought
uh damn long neck up and on stage at the
end of the first show and we sang we are
the world with a beautiful group
we had some diversity up there we got a
couple tino's up there
uh you know a couple dark aardvarks up
there we had a beautiful
we had a beautiful squad we had a girl i
think who was
i don't even know dude freaking great
you know awesome and so everybody was up
there
and it was we saying we are the world
together i'm gonna try to get that video
for you
but but yeah it was uh
it was just a good experience man it was
a good experience uh and i'm glad he got
to coming down
and i'm just glad i got to kind of chat
with him and see what his little
what his world is like on a one-to-one
basis and i found him to just be like a
nice kid
you know just nice and just you know
just
i mean just imagine any anybody else
from a community that's kind of a
troubled community
and there's not a lot of opportunity and
who gets this kind of
weird uh or unique instagram
popularity uh
so it was interesting man it was
interesting
but i'm glad that he came out and i'm
grateful that to everybody that came
through
i'll tell you this dude they had uh oh
i'll tell you this actually that today's
episode is brought to you by
grey block pizza gray block pizza they
have
you sometimes you need a you need a
stylish pie you need that slice of nice
and they have it there it's 1811 pico
boulevard in los angeles on the way to
the beach
great block pizza get that hitter
get that hitter today's episode is also
brought to you by
ship station when you're selling online
get
getting your orders out can be a real
pain oh what's that pain
oh that's getting my orders out were you
in a fire
no just been getting a lot of orders out
it's time consuming
it's expensive getting your orders out
it takes i mean
you know you sell something but you
spend a whole day just shipping two of
them it's like oh how am i gonna solve
this
that's why you need ship station
shipstation.com
it's the fastest easiest most affordable
way to manage and ship your orders
shipstation helps you get orders out
quickly
not slowly you see somebody with a slow
ass order bro what are you doing
get a quick order you can save money on
shipping costs
keep your customers happy hey hey
ooh i'm a customer i'm joined up
no matter where you're selling amazon
etsy your own website
ship station brings all your orders into
one
simple interface ship station works with
all the major carriers
including usps fedex ups
even amazon fulfillment so you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you
and your customer instead of going to
all the different websites and all the
options
and checking each one shipstation does
all that
it's the number one choice of online
sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
available and right now this past
weekend listeners
can try ship station for free for 60
days
when you use promo code theo
there's absolutely no risk you can start
your free trial
without even entering your credit card
info
just visit shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in theo t-h-e-o that's
shipstation.com
and enter promo code theo
shipstation.com make
ship happen you know and i put a photo
up on instagrams of
of me and uh of david damn longneck and
some of his buddies and i didn't know
any of the other guys really i've seen
some of their stuff online but
and people like you know one guy is like
i
i can't i can't support this type of
stuff you know
you support these types of people
and it just made me kind of mad it's
like what do you mean these types
you know pete what you think he's a
privileged kid
i mean i know he's a silly kid at 19. he
makes ridiculous stuff online
you know but you think that kid is
privileged some young kid growing up in
flint michigan
you think he has some special
opportunity
you know it just like
you know it's like i don't know and then
it also i feel bad because it made me
think like oh well
like i don't spend i'm you know
i mean uh david reminds me of people
that i grew up around
you know he reminds me of the
neighborhood that i grew up in
dude i'll tell you this bra show up to
the improv
he's outside him and his gang bro he's
got a wild cat with him named gucci
berry and this guy he's probably 50
years old
you know half half of his teeth he's
always getting people beating them in
the uh
nuts and stuff online it's to me it's
not my vibe really
really at all really but he's a nice guy
and uh i roll up to the improv they're
out front with
no shirts on
zero shirts dude i've been
i've gone to the enterprise for 15 years
i've gone
to the improv in hollywood california on
melrose avenue
never once have i seen
someone without a shirt on there but
today
i roll up there sitting out front no
shirts boy
i said gang gang baby
it's people you know p
it's people you want i mean it's just
it's people man
and the second i feel like i'm not
people man i don't care what they i
don't care if
if if dave is black or white or latino
or
you know peruvian or uh veruca salt or
whatever he is
you know i don't care if he [ __ ] you
know reaches into his pants and pulls
out a damn tail
that's people so
anyway i shouldn't and it didn't bother
me it just made me
i don't know part of me did worry it was
like well what if you know if if people
think that i'm associated with these
kind of people or if they think i'm this
then
then what is that going to be i guess it
i guess in the end i guess i'm really
just disappointed that it made me
doubt myself you know it made me think
well
what are people going gonna think
because i like to you know i wish i
didn't live in that space where i
worried about that
while i worried about what people
thought what's in their heads
about me
and i hope to get there you know i hope
to aim to be in that space more
um and i don't even know how
how i ever got there probably when i was
young well i think probably i didn't
know how i felt about myself
you know i had no real self-awareness
and the only way i did feel about myself
wasn't good
so of course i'm gonna need other people
to like me
i'm gonna need them to feel good
because that's the only way i know if
i'm doing okay
you know if i ask myself it's like
yelling into a cave
when i was young
so it almost makes sense that i even do
work as a comedian
because it's like i needed to know that
that it's like i got my own feeling of
feeling okay from them
so it's almost like i'm trying to think
about this a little more
i know in a simple way it's like oh what
do what people think about you that
oh you care about what people think
about you yes
but i'm trying to think about how i
you know i i
got what i thought about myself
from
[Music]
how other people responded to me i think
that really
is more how what was going on with me
you know because that's the only way i
knew
you know ness so
yeah nobody you know i just wasn't
filled up with hey you're
you know euro you're okay there wasn't
enough of those
and if there were maybe there weren't i
couldn't even hear them
and that's where sometimes you it's like
man we're all special ed
we're all special needs
you know and it makes me feel good to
know that there's a lady out there
hey theo i'm calling from venus arizona
i'm the special ed who's driving
somewhere
to take care of some kids man that's
great
that's awesome it's nice to know that
there is when these kids get home
that this guy hello my name is tim and i
listen to
your podcast after i drop my kids off
at school i'm a stay-at-home dad that
when the kids get off the bus
timmy's out there with a little tray of
muffins or um
or a cigarette i don't know if the kids
smoke or what he does with his kids but
he's out there
that's nice to know that the you know
that people
that that we're filling these youngsters
up
with some type of connection
um i'm just kind of rambling but uh
but yeah what else is going on with me
right now um
hmm
you know i'm trying to i've just been
trying to think about like
you know this just
just kind of
i guess just kind of wanting to just
i've just been feeling so busy sometimes
that i don't know
it's hard to know like if i'm feeling
okay or not so i gotta just gotta try
and check in with myself a little bit
more
and just kind of you know just make sure
that i'm doing okay and i feel like i am
um it was just you know i used to have
just kind of more time to just
you know i guess just even chill out or
take a nap or get a little
uh frosty or something i love frosties
and i love what else do i love you know
what i miss i was thinking about the
other day
musical chairs do remember musical
chairs
remember at school i don't even know
when it happened
but about once every two years
some new legislation came down at school
and they once again allowed kids to play
musical chairs
that's where they put like seven chairs
in the middle of a room and they put
like
40 kids in the room and it was just
bonkers you remember how crazy it was
you remember it it was like uh
it was almost like the royal rumble like
wwf royal
rumble and they had everybody all
suddenly ever you start to see who
people are
you'd have a little you know a couple
sets of twins these two females brother
over there sharpening their teeth with a
real file you're like damn
these [ __ ] get in a seat
suddenly all the white kids were like oh
we're gonna have a chance to do
something athletically
musical chairs
and then the music would start all
around the mulberry bush
[Music]
and people are just
just eyeing the other person suddenly a
friend was
not a friend at all suddenly some kid
had just reached in his bag and just
painted his face up like
william wallace
you know he's like we are free tell them
scotland is
free other kids was getting scared one
kid
fainted bruh dude whatever son
you out bro you out you can't handle
musical chairs you ain't gonna handle
musical the rest of your life then go
move to somewhere else bruh and be weak
daddy we gotta go
and then it would stop and it would and
people you'd see some kid pull out a
blade
you know some rich kid would bring a
chair from home you're like
what fauntleroy's oh
that's it he's cheating they had some
pedos on the side
betting on it laying money you know plus
750 on little reginald over there
and the teacher was smoking cigarettes
it was insane and then
just all these cheeks flying it was butt
first
it was butt first
and there's just nothing more just
quirky and silly than a bunch of
children's
butts all flying in the same direction
at once
and you had to get cheek to seat some
kids they go for a chair
miss it completely shatter their legs
shatter their spine
end up in a bag once you know end up
traveling by sack
for the rest of their lives on their on
their on their dad or mom's back if
their mom was strong
just you know just you had to get two
cheeks on the seat
and it was yours and you had somebody
yelling in the distance somebody be
yelling cheek that seat
cheek that seat
there's people crawling through pop
pipes full of duty they said it would
take a minute 600 years i gotta say a
prison
but musical chairs randall did it in
less than 20.
and you know little daniel's back there
in the back he got him a little santa
sack and he's not even playing he's just
stealing people's stuff i mean he's back
there he's taking these like just
mom-made sandwiches and game boys and
just filling up a sack and he's just
he leaped out the window right in
under the back of a greyhound he left
town that we never even saw
because you know daniel you know he
makes his own choices
but damn boy musical chairs the game
ends some
it came down to two people one chair
and it was actually kind of a great
thing for regular life this is regular
life
it's gonna be survival of the of the
of the fittest you got to get that ass
right
because it's cheek first sometimes you
got to put your ass
on the line
and one you know somebody when you don't
and that you win and they supposed to
give you some candies
and they go in the cupboard and who
knows some little [ __ ] kid
ate all of them lime slices some
sneaky little white boy that polly
nicaragua
snacked up all the lime slices and
little daniel he's already he's halfway
to tacoma
and he got that bag of you know maybe
lukewarm muffins and some ham
sandwiches and some pudding packs bruh
and he's keyed up come
on boy get in there
man i just i mean it was god's game
i mean that was god's game man
let's get into a couple more calls uh
uh here's one we got as always the
hotline is 985-664-9503
and the hotline is um you know it's a
it's a it's just you know if something's
going on what's happening
if you're not if you're struggling with
something uh if there's something that
we can try to do to help
um if you want to share a response to
something on the show
you can always hit it and again it's
985-664-9503
let's take a call right here hey what's
going on theo
it's jonathan from shreveport what's up
sharif port
uh and i used to the cops after the
comedy
the cops would come by these bicycle
cops and they would tase you if you
wanted
and you could you didn't even have to be
a criminal and they would tase you with
the damn taser
so you know they got some rare uh
kind of tourist attractions around there
let's hear more
man i was listening to the podcast
earlier and
you were talking about being in a
relationship i think you're
39 and i'm 35
man and i was scared of relationships
just like you for a long time
because like i come from alcoholic
parents and a broken home and
all that [ __ ] and man
it was like oh and dealing drugs for
a long time it was like everybody was
business
related or business oriented like i had
girlfriends but they were more like
homeboys you know
oh yeah drugs will make a will turn a
girlfriend in
into more of a girl fiend you know
onward
but i met stephanie the woman i'm with
now
and dude it really changed me i mean
she's a genuine person
so it is worth
the risk to face the fear i would say
gang man i appreciate you saying that
dude and
yeah uh yeah i guess everybody needs a
little stephanie on
them everybody needs
yeah i'm sure somebody comes along and
kind of just makes it
i mean my biggest fear i think right now
in like a practical sense
on a surface sense is i i just don't i
don't know that i trust myself not to
cheat not to you know i still i got that
sugar lizard sometimes
in my wiener you know in my body weiner
and you know if that lizard gets
thinking bruh
then i'll you know i'll get pink and you
feel me i mean that's kind of
obtuse and i want to say that but i try
to get out there looking for some loin
you know i'll get out there kind of just
just kind of just stand then around
just kind of looking for some trim
trimming them whatever you say i
am you know mom's spaghetti bro you feel
me
i'll take a girl out for mom's spaghetti
to try to freaking
serve up that meatball you gotti
so i i just i don't know sometimes man i
think that's one of the things
and then i i [ __ ] bro i got so many
[ __ ] problems bro
jesus christ dude i might as well just
build a church around my damn head and
my heart
i might as well you know what i should
do is just live in a church
or something like that it would help or
a tp or a native american church
let's hear more you sound like you might
be on a couple of leads as well daddy
you might be
you know a couple milligrams deep right
now onward
cause now that i got kids everything's
different man
like i stopped doing everything illegal
started making legal money i mean it's
it's been a real real long road but it's
really worth it
and i didn't trust anybody man
at one time if i couldn't make a dollar
off of you i didn't really mess with you
dang bro wow yeah so i you know i feel
you and a lot of that is yeah it's like
you got to have
opportunity for transformation and it
sounds like somebody real special came
along and uh
and made you believe in something
greater than yourself and that's pretty
powerful
you know i'm amazed at the way that
that goodness really works in the world
you know i'm just amazed man um
i'm amazed at how many people you know
i'm feeling in some type of way
negative or this or that and somebody
comes along and
their positivity just shows me the other
half of the world that
or the really the other most of the
world that i'm not seeing
you know because if i'm seeing things
negatively is a lot of that's my choice
you know you walk into hell with a smile
bruh
i mean you could even you might even be
able to make the devil think different
you know it's just powerful sometimes to
just uh
do that contrary action
oh it's easy to show up at work and be a
dick and do this and that
it it's hard some guy works for you or
you work for your boss he's a dick or
you're a dick
to show up and just i'm gonna try this
different
what if today i walked up and said just
hey look
what you might be the best damn employee
or employer
they might be the worst and if you said
hey look
what can i do differently to help the
situation here
even if you you might already be doing
it great but that right there is gonna
make them think damn is the world
changing because i thought my boss or i
thought the guy working under him i
thought he was an [ __ ]
wow the world's changing it's really the
world people are start are asking what
can they do to help somebody
wow i better get on that bus
because i'm over here on this other
shitty bus there's only one other person
on it
it's a young fella named daniel brown he
got a sack full of game boys
so i don't i got to get on this new bus
that's headed in a new direction
and that's my perspective and i i think
i'm sounding a little bit preachy man
i'm sorry about that i
you know i've been having a my patience
has just been real short with myself and
i noticed sometimes i get preachy when
um
when i just when i haven't been resting
enough really
and when i haven't been at peace enough
i just or when i've been too busy i get
more preachy
so i'm not trying to preach at you i'm
i'm really trying to tell myself that i
you know i want to be brave enough when
when a situation is shitty
when somebody's done something wrong to
me
instead of saying hey [ __ ] you
i want to be able to say hey
how can i help man
what's going on you're upset today you
you need to make it five extra dollars
off of me go on bro
get that money that's gonna change
that's gonna
you know nine extra dollars off of it
today that's going to make you
you're going to sit at home and be full
of you're going to take it daddy
i don't know i do i'll give you [ __ ]
i'll give you 14
i'll give you 14 you take the nine and
then here's an extra five
go home and don't be an [ __ ] to your
family how about that
i'll pay you every day to go home and
not be an [ __ ] to your family
you know let them have it man
i just i don't know i guess i got i'm
spinning bruh i'm getting preachy man
i'm sorry about that
but thanks for calling man and uh and
sorry i was thinking you were on
quaaludes but you dog you sound like you
might
look if they have a quaalude competition
dude or voice over work
if they ever come out with a smurf or
something that's on luge bruh
you know sneaky you know snakey dopey
doc
sneezy uh
you know opioid bruh you could audition
for him bro you got that looty
you got that looty bat that baritone
ludi
you get that looty looty baritone you
got about 600 milligrams in your voice
box daddy
and i love you man gang gang shreveport
all day
and i'm ready to see dustin poirier
whoop that boyz
over there in the desert
operation diamond storm baby we coming
back to the middle east
it's gonna get rogue man and speaking of
rogue there's actually a new uh
a friend of mine created a game called
streets of
rogue and it's uh it's on steam it's on
xbox one it's on playstation
um and it's kind of like
what's that uh game
like pep boys no it's uh
grand theft auto it's a grand that's
automated zelda
and you could do anything you want if
you'd like to live in like an
alternative world
on this on his game you can you know you
can be doing cigarettes you can be doing
karate
you know you could light people up or
just light up a smoke
uh you can you know you could kill
people you can have drinks and
everything there's all types of stuff
juggle make chocolates um
they got tons of opportunities on there
and then you can still be like the mayor
of the whole
of the whole you know little universe on
there so
um yeah if you want to check it out it's
called streets
of rogue and uh and that's
my friend matt made the game he's a game
maker
and actually he just got married as well
so uh congratulations uh
matsky out there what else
let's get into a couple more uh
questions and calls that came in here we
go
yo what's going on baby it's kazzy over
here in charlotte
what's up qazi over there in charlotte
huh and i love charlotte
you want to go to a city that's really
white rific and blacktastic at the same
time boy
charlotte you want to see uh
you know cities that are really just you
know they got that
funky they got funky but also
honky you know they got that honky funk
uh
vibe going on and that really is
charlotte man one of the best southern
restaurants i've ever been to
is right over there off of by that mall
over there downtown
and it's dangerous because the buses go
fast there
so you could you could lose a family
member to a bus but god damn them hush
puppies are good you know
so you could uh you could have a you
could have those in a
couple orders that have fried catfish at
the wake
you know at the funeral baby onward i
was watching some king
king of the bee whatever it is and you
and brandon was talking about
uh superpowers or something and you said
that you could go in the bathroom
and you could tell for the last time
that somebody
did some business in there was well oh
yeah that's something that uh
it's a i don't think it's a soup i guess
it is a superpower i guess i don't know
if everybody could do it but
yeah if i go into a urinal restroom or
you know piss area
if i say if somebody's been in there
doing a duty or something i can
sometimes
i could smell i could almost i can't
help but smell it
like right when i walk in my my nose
will take a hit and i'll try to
it'll be like oh yeah somebody did or no
somebody did or it's been you know nine
and a half minutes or it's been 60
seconds or
you know they got two boys you know
playing these porcelain pipes right
there
you know in a couple stalls right now
they got active shooters in the building
homework well
it made me think man if you're ever over
here in charlotte i work at this little
text message joint
called chewie's come drop into chewie's
we've got
you know the women's restroom and the
men's restroom and then we've got what
we call the family bathroom
but what it is it's a whole different
bathroom it's got you know one toilet in
there it's really for changing kids but
all the co-workers go in there with your
drugs
and um and i didn't say that and we use
that and we do our own business but it
always smells fresh
we got the uh the janitorial uh folks
shout out to them
loretta and i hear you know anybody
who's listening to this shout out to
y'all
but um hell yeah shout out to anybody to
be ever cleaning toilets man
and i used to clean him over there at
bj's pizza house off of 190
and i used to get me a cold beer and uh
and i'd go in the bathroom
i was probably 13 or 14. and i drinking
beer out of a damn paper cup and i'd be
hitting that
that miller light bro and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] made my
cheeks made [ __ ] made just
made it feel like squirrels were living
in my neck and they were
looking each other they were looking for
each other to [ __ ] you know that's what
it felt like when i drink that miller
light as a kid
second it poured in it was so spicy and
hot in my
and just i mean it was ice cold but it
was just hot inside of it
it was coldness but that alcohol had
heat in it and it would get in my throat
and just let the damn squirrels loose
and that [ __ ]
made me boy did i bite my own ass cheek
open if i had
you know two sips of miller light at the
age of 13.
um onward
yeah i did the most work in the
restaurant
they always keep it smelling great in
there you'll go in there you you won't
even know
the last time that anyone's done some
business oh that's beautiful
so y'all i'll i'll have to hit that
chewie's when i'm local
um oh i used to love bruh so
i used to do whippets i used to get bro
i go lock myself in the uh
if the toilet was taken i'd go hit lock
myself in the
freezer at the restaurant and i'd be
just eating handfuls of bread pudding
straight out of the uh like the chef
would have made it all but he was
cheating on his wife and he was
he was embezzling money so nobody gave a
[ __ ] about his recipes right because
really i want to know what ingredients
are
going into your soul before the what's
in the uh
in the dessert tray what you put in
there so i want to know that first batch
of you
before i see that you know that that
second course
and so i'd get in there i just beat
handfuls of bread pudding and doing
whippets bruh
i'd be dude people come in there i
remember one guy came in
and uh he's like dude what the [ __ ] he
doing in here
he was a co-worker and i was like hold
on just a second
is he just gonna be one of you guys
today that's how
whipped it out i was i thought i was at
the hostess stand
and this guy came in and i tried to seed
him
in the damn freezer bruh so
you just got to know who you are you
know or know who you are
i think
let's take another call right here here
we go thank you for hitting the hotline
for being here with me this weekend
or this monday actually man yo
what up you freaky said what up man uh
nelson here calling from texas
what's up nelson from tejas and i
appreciate you ringing in papa onward
uh last time i called the show was about
a year ago
uh to be exact last summer on the
halfway to christmas episode and i
believe i was the first mailman
to call your show i'm actually on the
job right now
gang boy nelson out there and it's
halfway to christmas
let's hear more and just want to remind
you
it's halfway to christmas buddy am i
here uh freelance elephant again
swinging these letters uh and i just
want to say you've been keeping me going
man appreciate what you do
and uh keep on keeping on brother gang
gang gang papa nelson out there
and nelson bro he's uh that's that's uh
jolly old saint nelsonless saint nicka
nelson right there dude my man
halfway to christmas nelson bro htc
nelson there there
and yeah it's that time of year people
don't realize
you know the mailman he's been laying
low you know he's been at the house a
lot
you know having fruit roll-ups you know
storing nuts in his cheeks doing
calf lifts and in the garage
trying to get ready get keyed up get
ready
because the second half of the year they
start training
you'll see a mailman at night running
down the street with a huge sack of
[ __ ] nothing bro
then a couple weeks later you'll see him
out there with a sack of uh
you know fake bricks or something a
little bit more than nothing
they start training you'll see a mailman
get a big bag and start
you know stretching it out making sure
testing really testing the
the guttural strength of a bag
and they did they they getting ready
we don't know that mailman that they
want to you know a lot of mailmen
they just they just want to be of
service man
a lot of mailmen they they're gonna go
they get they dropping off something
good
make a little larry happy you know
suddenly a bunch of kids in town need a
game boy because somebody stole all
their game boys
and that's daniel bruh and you know
daniel man he makes his own choices
and you gotta you gotta love the mailman
when you see that guy you salute him huh
you that's that overnight bad boy that's
that second day air
you gotta hit him up with that bail
you know anybody also these guys there
all day they got perfume
samples in the bag they huffing those
[ __ ]
a mailman there's no way
if i'm not a mailman that i ain't
getting hopped up on
uh perfume samples all day
dude i'll be you know i'll drop a
package here drop a package there
next thing you know i do about four open
that thing up and do about four hits of
cool water cologne right there to the
dome
right just do nine hits that uh that
burberry stout or whatever
dude i'd be so high on perfume samples
bruh i deliver the mail and then go
undeliver it dude i'll deliver i [ __ ]
i'll put four
rainbow four uh reindeers in front of my
mail truck and
and just drive that [ __ ] around and
feed them [ __ ] beer and give them
little hits
give them a hits of uh of um
what else they got uh that ralph lauren
that polo scent scent hit him with that
fresh fresh by the face
face for the snout boy come on
it's different man we living
it's halfway to christmas and thank you
nelson for reminding us
so let's get in the spirit now don't be
one of these december these grinches
man don't be one of these grinches it's
an inch to christmas and they get
now they're getting a little bit ready
but i'm starting
early surely
let's take one more call here here we go
onward hey theo
this is matt from kentucky hey matthew
thank you for calling in and it's
beautiful over there beautiful hill
country over there
in lexington man wanna it's a real real
special place over there onward
i was fortunate enough to see you uh
last
uh last year like november december down
in lexington kentucky
down at the uh comedy off broadway
and man you killed it the question
i have man is uh i want to know
something that
i'm shocked nobody has asked so far
theo buddy are you happy man
i love you bob i love you
love you too man i appreciate you coming
out there um
and while you were talking i was just
thinking too uh i want to
just let everybody know i hope y'all are
staying dry and safe that's caught up in
the storm and been dealing with barry
you know barry he you know
you don't know and things can get happen
you got water in the house and
suddenly you know your kids are you know
they're playing water games or they're
doing white
water rafting off of the dish cabinet or
something
you got to make the most of it if you
can but i hope everybody's staying safe
and put some floaties on put you put
some floaties on your loved ones when
you tuck them in the bed
because uh mother nature you know she
wants to work with us
but she fiery
you know how these miatas can be
sometimes
and she's feisty she's gonna flex man
mother nature's gonna flex
uh am i happy you know ah you know
what's so funny i
i mean um i think i'm always thinking
about this i think
everybody's always thinking are they
happy hmm
you know i don't know man i don't i
don't know if i'm happy with this
episode of this podcast
i've been feeling overwhelmed recently
man i've been feeling like
um you know a lot of it is i've just
been feeling like i
you know i used to i felt before like i
knew exactly who i was and then
as things have gotten busier with work
sometimes i don't know uh
i still know who i am but um i just need
to focus more on
i just i don't need to focus more but i
just need to do more things of service
to be
of service i think uh
i think that'll make me happier you know
on tuesday i got a thing i'm going to do
um movie night over by the ronald
mcdonald house
and ronald mcdonald he don't do just
burgers man they do uh
they have a good charitable organization
where they house people that
i have family members that are in icu
and stuff like that and you can go
and so they put them up in this hotel
that's free
and it's uh and so they have all these
families and these children that stay in
the hotels while the kids are getting
long-term
care at hospitals and so
you know i decided i was gonna go i used
to do tuesday nights over there and so
i'm starting back uh this week
so i'm excited about that before king
and the sting we're doing king and the
sting uh just a live show it's just me
and brendan
but we're doing that live um
and uh and we're gonna do i'm gonna go
to the ronald mcdonald house before we
do a movie night so i'm excited about
that
you know i think i just need to make
sure that i focus on doing things that
do make me feel good
i think i feel a lot of responsibility
because i've been given
you know you get more opportunities
you know as as my career has changed in
the past year
i feel uh
you know i feel like i can do more
at the same time i feel like i need to
find ways to
be happy with what's going on you know i
just want to
i don't know man am i happy yes yes i am
i'm very happy man i get to go
you know i'm happy i'm happy when i get
oh man i got off stage on friday night
or saturday night
man i just saw so many people in the
hall and it was just great we just had a
great time
you know i just i i just love seeing
people be happy they come out with their
wives
people some people came out their first
show they'd never even been out to a
show before this fella sebastian
somebody else
this other guy and his brother you know
a couple they've never been to a show
before
they've never been to a comedy show and
then they come out and laugh
and i don't feel like oh you know look
at me i just feel like oh man we
because i need them to laugh for me to
feel okay so we're out here this is a
this is a team effort and that kind of
stuff does does make me really happy
i think the things that i'll let get
into me that make me unhappy are
if i start thinking other people should
be a certain way that's the kind of
stuff i don't like
like if i get caught up like in too much
like thinking about political stuff
or you know thinking that i know
something that
that i know more than others
man i i may have different experiences
but ever
you know that doesn't mean that i know
anything else more
you know everybody can learn something
from everybody else and
um and also i gotta realize some stuff
it's not my battle it's not my fight
you know it's not my
you know i just can't i need to do what
i can do around those are
that are close to me um to be loving
i need to you know i'd like to be less
hard on myself people always remind me
of that and thank you for all the nice
messages that i get about that kind of
stuff
um
[Music]
you know i just it hurts me when people
when i see you know young guy
i mean when i see anybody that's
struggling
you know and it just makes me
you know we can just do better i think
and i'm not saying you can do better i'm
just saying
and then all i can do is just do better
you know this is life this is a it's
it's a great opportunity right to be
alive
and uh
but yeah i just feel i guess some sense
of responsibility that
um since i have some sort of a platform
not that i could tell anybody what to do
or how to be or anything
but i do feel uh
i don't know i guess i feel some
responsibility to um
well it's like i i just want to
i don't know man it's like i i i am
happy
you know i am happy i just um
i'm grateful for you know for for the
fun stuff i get to do
i get to be in this fun circle where
like dude i get to talk to joe rogan
sometimes i get to
um dude i get to meet single moms who
you know and and and give him a hug like
i wanted to hug my mom when i was young
and just
you know or be a part or like you know
help out with our
patreon group and help to you know do
you know try and do something nice for
them
like yeah i get to do a lot of things
that make me feel good
um but i think there's something in me
that always wants her to be something
else i always want to keep moving the
carrot
uh and i think like
you know i want to be able to you know
that's why i put
i decided i want to go do the ronald
mcdonald house again and start that back
up because
i need something also to just make sure
that i stay in a place
um where i realize like what's important
you know for me you know i don't want to
get disconnected man i don't ever want
to
uh
i don't ever want to look at somebody
that needs help
and think like uh you know or uh
or or look at anybody like that
you know that's the same way that i felt
like people looked at me a lot of my
life
you know people always think like oh you
know that
you know i can only speak from my
perception that like you know poor white
kids have you know they have all this
opportunity everybody has that just if
they have a white skin they have this
opportunity or
everybody struggles man everybody i
don't care who they are
i don't care if they're wealthy i don't
care if they're not i don't care it
doesn't matter
you know struggles that hunter baby
struggles that hunter
and it gots all the you know it got to
all the weaponry
i just don't you know i don't want to
miss the opportunity to be
used to be helpful
that's what it is man that's it that
would make me happy you know if i know
that each day i try to
put myself in a position
or show up enough to the day
where if i can be helpful to somebody
else that
not only am i excited about it but i'm
willing to do it
and and of course that'll never happen
all the time it'll
never happen but
but that would make you know that that
that's kind of what makes me feel good
you know it just makes me feel good dude
it just makes me
because the truth is that's a lot of
what's going on dude uh
you know i wish that the that people
know what's going on
you know i get upset sometimes at the
media and all that kind of [ __ ] they
don't care they don't know
they're in a business but i feel like
people know what's going on
and i feel like we're headed in a good
direction man i feel like there's a lot
of
man there's a lot of love on the streets
and there's a lot more right around the
corner bro
so i don't even know if that answers
your question man i don't even know what
i'm talking about
but but i know that for me my battle is
like just making sure that i'm just
taking care of myself enough to be
to be present enough so i'm not missing
an opportunity
um to be of service in some way because
that makes me feel good
you know it makes me feel good uh so
anyway i'm kind of rambling but
let's take another call that came in
right here and then um
and then maybe we'll scoot off of this
episode and
and man uh thank you guys so much
halfway to christmas i'm gonna have to
start thinking about what i want you
know
yo what up ceo my name is connor i'm
from i'm from
pittsburgh and uh today is actually my
my 22nd birthday
oh awesome man happy 22nd connor
um oh and it's conor mcgregor's birthday
i think was yesterday
so that's kind of crazy and um i just
wanted to say that
i'm a massive fan my uh my brother
actually got me into you
and uh this past year has been a been a
pretty uh tough year for me i uh
our mom's been battling cancer and and
um i really just wanted to
to use this outlet to kind of thank my
brother because he's been the most
amazing person
through the whole situation and i've
been at college so i don't have a whole
lot of money so he's been
he takes me out every weekend he shows
me a good time and he's helped me
through a really rough breakup and
he's just the most amazing guy he flew
us out to denver
to visit our cousin and um i just wanted
to spread a little bit of positivity
because
you know he's a huge listener and he got
me into you and he gave me a laugh every
every monday and thursday
and um i just really wanted to say thank
you and
you know have a great week man gang
gang gang bro that's cool man well
that's nice that your brother cares like
that
that's cool man that's cool bro
that's cool that you got you know your
brother you guys are out there
you guys are on the front lines for the
family you know you got cancer on the
you know on the horizon but you guys got
it in your scopes with your hearts and
you guys are caring about each other
dude and just trying you know
man it's crazy how much my brother is it
makes me think of my own brother
and i'm sure there's a lot of people who
live you know whoever's listening to
this
this [ __ ] right now that uh
are thinking about their brother man
dude my brother used to make me listen
to all of his music that's the only
thing i knew about music
it's still only kind of type of music i
really even know people ask me about
music
i'm like uh i don't i listen to maybe
rodney james dio
tesla you know i listen to some nwa i
listen um
i listen to whatever my brother listened
to
you know it's funny when you're young
and stuff you just want to be your
brother so bad even if he beats you
like damn my brother beat my ass but
damn bruh
he's awesome you know you just want to
be your brother so bad it's so
interesting how that happens at that age
you know it's a special gift i know
there's a lot of single uh you know not
single kids out there but
uh hopefully there's a ton of single
kids out there but
um but there's a lot of kid children
that
you know they don't um what am i talking
about
there's a lot of kids that uh
yeah [ __ ] i don't know man but that's
nice dude it's nice that you care about
your brother and i'm glad that he
listens and i'm glad that you listen and
and i'm glad you guys are out there i'm
glad you got a teammate in the world
that's what i'm saying there's a lot of
kids that are just they're only children
and they only children so they don't
really get that opportunity so
it's like we all have this different
gift man we all have some people got a
gift some of it's on the inside some of
it's on the outside
some of us have a brother some of us
don't some of us have a sister
some of us have two children some of us
can't have children
some of us can juggle some of us can't
read
dude the guy that can't read oh yeah
sucks a lot of the times
but when he walks back by a [ __ ]
bookstore and feels
no uh regret
gold mine of comfort there's all the
every the two sides to the sword
you know there's two sides to every
sword bro and we just
you know i don't know [ __ ] i don't know
anything oh
isn't that amazing but i know that you
care about your brother
and that makes me feel good because it
makes me think about my brother dude
my brother's such a weird guy bro he's
so hard on himself dude but he's such a
loving guy
and uh and he tries his best and
you know and we just he and i were hard
on ourselves because we don't
you know we developed our own sense of
what was okay or what wasn't and we
didn't
you know nobody was nobody was hard on
us or easy on us
and so we didn't even know and and our
brains don't want to leave
you know sometimes if you develop your
own thing in your head
that thing can sometimes be mean
you know and but i know man my brother's
like my
you know he's my idol now and he's not
perfect i need and i'm
and i'm far from that and and we never
will be but
you know we have these little moments
and times where
you know he's just everything i always
wanted him to be and i'll never
probably fully be able to let him know
that but
but that's some of my journey you know i
get to be a brother in this lifetime
man that's cool you know i get to call
somebody who has the same blood i have
in my body in their body
and let them know hey man you know how's
that flow going bro we're riding on
on a risky river aren't we
but this blood is category four rapids
right now in it brother we boiling
or whatever's going on anyway
i'm rambling but uh
thank you guys so much for being a part
of this episode uh
whatever that even means i feel like
it's just
sometimes i like go in and like turn it
into like a radio dj
i don't know uh congrats to uriah faber
on his win
man i'll say this about uriah faber dude
i've shaken
i bet probably 6 000 people's hands in
my life
the strongest and heaviest hand
i've ever shook in my whole life
uriah fabers that guy has a damn
19 pound hand
i mean that guy uh
you look he got some real
he's real real handsy that fella um
he's one of a kind man and congrats to
him for coming back just
for having that that you know giving
himself that chance and taking that risk
that's brave
you know i'm fascinated by people that
are brave around me
constantly and uh and thank you guys for
calling in
uh you guys be good to yourselves man
i'm gonna try it we're gonna make it
we're gonna make it i'm gonna play this
on the way out actually because you know
uh this is bishop gun uh making it
i ain't seen home in about a hundred
days i can almost
mama pray for my restless soul
and i made a dollar i ain't spent but
well it's going ain't
killed me yet i still get where i'm
bound to go
[Music]
i'm making good time
gang gang man most all of my plans
slip right through my hands
[Music]
i wouldn't wear pants if i was out there
if i was a singer
but i'm making it
[Music]
good time
halfway to christmas guys we can do it
we can do it we got this
make a good time
i'm left here alone in my
[Music]
but i'm in pretty good shape
for the shape that i'm in
[Music]
i'm making you
i'm making good time
i make a good time
[Music]
i promise you i promise you we all
hundred days
i can almost
we're all gonna make it man
we all we're all special edmund we're
all special needs
you know we all
you know but santa's coming bro
gang man you guys be good to yourselves
thank you for being here for me today
you